we're joined now by the social housing
activist equation 20 boa thank you so
much for being with us on the program we
really appreciate it
um the case just breaks my heart at this
little boy I'm sure you must sort of
feel the same yeah I mean it's
absolutely horrific and I've been
campaigning for the last year and a half
to avoid a situation just like this but
what we've seen tragically with the case
of Arab is that he's paid the ultimate
price for um corporate neglect by his
landlord you surprised
no I can't say I am I mean it's an
absolute tragic case but from what I've
seen across the country in terms of
tenants living under
um social housing landlords whether that
be Housing Association or local
Authority is often they're living in
similar cases in some cases even worse
conditions for decades even I've spoken
to one tenant who reached out to me for
help after complaining for 27 years
that's longer than I've been alive yet
they weren't listened to I think that's
it isn't it the not being listened to
someone talking for 27 years and you
know the lawyers for awab's parent read
the statement from them they said we
cannot tell you how many health
professionals we've cried in front of
and Rochdale Borough Housing staff we
we've pleaded to expressing concern we
shouted out as loudly as we could I mean
they're just being ignored I mean it's
absolutely devastating his parents
complained before he was even born about
the dampened mold in his property yet
two years on it led to his death that
never should have been the case and I'm
sure they would have been complaining to
the likes of the repairs manager at
Rochdale borrow wide housing and they
haven't been talked about in this whole
conversation and complaints would have
gone directly to them they would have
overseen it and we've seen in the last
24 hours that there's others on Arabs
estate living in similar conditions four
years some people have complained for
this is a systemic issue not just
Rochdale borrow wide Housing Association
but across the sector why do you think
people aren't being too do you think
there's resources do you think it's
because of racism of class what what do
you think it is I think it's a I think
it's a mixture I mean racism in class
does massively come into it especially
from my experience but I also think it's
a stigma with social housing tenants
it's a cultural issue within the housing
sector and the fact is landlords can get
away with it due to the lack of
Regulation I mean for example we're
often told civilians nobody is above the
law and I think in the case of bad
landlords they they shouldn't be exempt
from that either especially in cases
like our where it costs the life of an
innocent individual so Gareth swarbrick
has been removed from his post as chief
executive of Rochdale Borough wide
housing that's the Housing Association
that rented the house Michael gave has
written to every Council leader in
England and social housing provider
do you think that change is coming
well I have to say in the case of
um
uh Rochdale Borough wide housings chief
executive having to be fired is an
insult and disgrace and I think it
represents
um the culture again within within
housing and directors boards the fact of
directors boards only 24 hours ago was
agreeing that he should stay in his post
even after that story comes out is
insulting for me so I can't imagine what
it's like
um for the family do I think change
comes change should have come five and a
half years ago after grenfell we should
not be sat here having a conversation
about an innocent two-year-old and dying
as a result of the neglect of his
landlord but here we are and change
really should have come then so I really
hope it does I really hope the sector
wakes up and does their jobs realizes
that it's people's lives they're dealing
with it's not just a nine to five I
think that's what the problem is what
would your message be right now to
Michael Gove you're obviously a very
eloquent spokesperson for many many
people right across the country what
would your message be to him well I've
met I've spoken to Michael Gove and his
team several times and I'm glad the
regulations coming in it needs to come
in a lot quicker and I don't think we're
being tough enough with bad landlords I
think in cases like this to avoid cases
like this we honestly need criminal
charges now if it was any other sector
if this was the NHS for example and it
was a doctoral nurse who had neglected
their patient in this way and it
resulted to a death Not only would they
be struck off that wouldn't even be
disputed there would also be a criminal
investigation open that we need to see
it in within housing too because it's
people's lives they're dealing with like
I said earlier not just the nine to five
I just want to sort of pause and give
people a bit of a sense about the
conditions that we're talking about we
can show a video uh of the concept I
just woke up and it's getting worse
right absolute ridiculous look at this
right
do you call this condensation what the
hell is that look
that is not a condensation look at this
look and it smells its rank is
disgusting and I'm not putting up with
this right you expect people to live in
conditions like this come on right you
see on the window there's condensation
but the roof shouldn't be looking like
that come on
are you kidding me look at this it
smells and this is destroying the carpet
and the paint
I'll find that social yeah I mean I
posted that um 20 I think 24 hours after
um our story broke a couple of days ago
and I want to bring up this point about
damper mold because it's this
um huge misunderstanding with it and
often it's tenants blame for the
conditions that they're living in with
dampen mold they're told stop drying
your clothes indoors open your windows
turn your radiators on there are 300 000
different types of molds a lot of which
can grow in your homes and many of them
um require different ways to tackle it
however across the sector it's often the
case that landlords send out contractors
like in this case where it's just washed
off with a bit of bleach and they hope
that it doesn't come back or what they
do is they send a contract around to
paint over it and pretend it's not there
that's not how you deal with dampen mold
and now I hope they've learned that with
dampen mold it can cost your life what
kind of conditions do you see honestly
the list goes on I've seen people's
homes flooded with sewage raw sewage
I've seen people's homes filled with
cockroaches damp mice mold ceilings that
have collapsed I've taken tenants to a e
due to a ceiling past partially
collapsing on top of them I have seen it
or you wouldn't even let animals live in
these homes the homes that I've seen
um never mind human beings and I think
it's a absolute disgrace that in this
country we allow that to happen with the
resources that we have and I mean with
these housing associations for example
often the chief executives are paid
six-figure salaries or in terms of
surpluses it's in the hundreds of
millions they don't have an excuse about
not having enough money and funding it's
their priorities and lack of care and
talk to me a bit about your story how
did you come to be it sitting here what
how did you involve doing campaign so I
lived in um poor housing myself poor
social housing and we have been
complaining throughout to our landlord
for many many months if not years about
the district pair we were living in
again cockroaches my stamp mold kitchen
that was nearly 100 years old rotten no
bathroom
um no bathroom light no windows in the
bathroom and we My dad became ill he was
diagnosed with stage one esophageal
cancer in those those conditions that
progressed it was aggressive form of
cancer progressed to stage four he was
being fed for his stomached by nurses
three times a day in those conditions
they struggled to bathe him and steal
the landlord wouldn't do or fix or
remedy the property he then passed away
and things went from bad to worse we
were left over winter without a living
room ceiling and still they wouldn't
come and deal with the other issues and
I said enough was enough no ceiling when
you're living yes so
um it was three stories and it was the
middle floor and they had the ceiling
had partially collapsed due to a leak
they came and pulled the ceiling down in
October
um 2020 and they didn't put up until
January the following year and they
didn't fix any of the other issues at
that point either and I just had enough
and turned to social media put all the
images and videos up on there and it
went viral and disgraced the landlord
into not just completing the works in my
home but spending millions and having to
complete over 800 repairs on my estate
to other people's homes too because it
was falling to bits I'm really sorry
about your dad you know it's really you
know but it does feel like you know if
you use his death to make huge change
for lots of people thank you um just
finally you know be brutal I am very
aware of our responsibility and do you
feel that sometimes there's too much
focus on
people who pay higher rate of tax people
who own their own homes and not enough
on rented housing on social housing
absolutely I think this issue with poor
social housing and social housing social
housing crisis anyway has existed
um for many decades before I was even
born people have been suffering I think
more needs to be more Focus needs to be
put on that that's where the real issues
are that's where people's lives are
being put at risk and I sometimes think
if um
before 2017 it was seen as a focus and
it was like all over the news and peas
were talking about it could we have
potentially avoided the tragedy that was
grenfell had we have spoken about this
earlier thank you so much for being on
the program it's been really interesting
to talk and to see some of the footage
as well really quite sobering thank you
for having me thank you